but we turn now to a story about a
professor with a creative approach to
closing the gender gap in science women
make up about half of the U.S population
but earn only a quarter of bachelor's
degrees in physics for women's History
Month are Jamie wax traveled to Texas to
meet some who is working to change that
by sharing the joy of science amazing
that's cool ready
the way Dr Tatiana eurokimova sees it
physics is Real World Magic
and with a little training all right
next anyone can become a real world
magician will the potato drop
let's check
videos of her experiments have ignited
people's curiosity online racking up
tens of millions of views over the last
two years you cannot explain much in
this short clips but you can get people
interested
yes you can inspire you get this part I
will tell you we filmed our
demonstrations and I never ever put
myself there I speak funny that's the
point people love the way you what's the
point no I never wanted to be in this in
this video students rolled the scenario
students were thinking how to explain it
students starting this video showing
these demonstrations she always wants
everything to be like a celebration of
science we met three of hirokimova's
former students two of whom work in the
world of physics today they all share a
special connection to the woman they
affectionately called Dr Tatiana you
walk into Dr Tatiana's classroom and you
can tell she wants you to be there and
not only that she wants to be there she
cares and she wants you to learn and
that makes you want to learn she never
makes you feel like you have to listen
you're like I know everything she wants
to hear everything that you have to say
so that way you can create something
together Dr Tatiana's Own Story starts
thousands of miles away about six hours
Northeast of Moscow before the breakup
of the Soviet Union she was raised by
two physicists and she married you
guessed it a physicist in 1999 she and
her husband Alexei moved to College
Station Texas where they both teach
today was it just complete culture shock
or did you know you were home of course
I didn't feel home but you make it home
over the last 20 years that home has
sounded a lot like this
when she isn't teaching
Dr Tatiana is doing Outreach
blowing the minds of future scientists
unexpected and very excited you were
part of this study with 10 000 students
and physicists and people in sciences
and the result was that men are no
better acclimated towards this than
women over 10 years there were no
consistent difference between a male and
female performance on this exams course
I felt that this is a very important
message for my students she's one of my
role models students like afia denani
who came to a m after seeing Dr
Tatiana's videos watching Dr Tatiana do
the experiments online especially since
she was a female leader it was more
inspiring for me to even go into physics
my very first semester I wasn't at class
that morning and she she looked at the
people that were sitting next to me she
was like where is Cali like you need to
call her right now and make sure that
she's okay I just overslept passed my
alarm I was like wow like she knows when
she notices when you're not there what
would you want
her to know about what she's done for
you everything that she did to push me
throughout my undergrad I've sort of
learned how to do that for myself so I
can be my own Advocate now because of
her what would you like to do that you
haven't done to start new programs
they're just not stuff so don't stop no
not still
there is nothing like a great teacher
and the next item on Dr Tatiana's agenda
is a M's physics and Engineering
Festival which he's extremely
enthusiastic about that happens next
month it attracts thousands of people to
campus each year and all are welcome
because as she says you don't need to be
a musician to go to a music festival so
why would you need to be a scientist to
celebrate science isn't that great she's
a pipeline oh my gosh it's just so
enthusiastic yes the Infectious energy
of this woman was just I mean you can
see it coming across the table at me
it's not just the explosions in her
experiments you know and so many girls
don't think that they're good at science
or math because that's kind of a
stereotype out there she is just getting
that enthusiasm young to increase the
pipeline it's amazing as the husband of
a woman who works in stem I will tell
you that she was very enthusiastic about
those results that women are no less
acclimated for Sciences than men it's a
beautiful thing that's a great piece
Jamie thank you very much thanks so much